Good evening, my fellow citizens.
This government, as promised, has maintained the closest surveillance of the Soviet military buildup on the island of Cuba.
Within the past week, unmistakable evidence has established the fact...
...that a series of offensive missile sites is now in preparation on that imprisoned island.
The purpose of these bases can be none other than to provide a nuclear strike capability against the Western hemisphere.
Only last Thursday, as evidence of this rapid offensive buildup was already in my hand,...
...Soviet Foreign Minister Gromyko told me in my office that he was instructed to make it clear once again,...
...as he said his government had already done, that Soviet assistance to Cuba, and I quote,...
"...pursued solely the purpose of contributing to the defense capabilities of Cuba,..."
...that, and I quote him, "Training by Soviet specialists of Cuban nationals in handling defensive armaments was by no means offensive,..."
"...and if it were otherwise," Mr. Gromyko went on, "the Soviet government would never become involved in rendering such assistance."
That statement also was false.
Acting, therefore, in the defense of our own security and of the entire Western hemisphere,...
...and under the authority entrusted to me by the constitution as endorsed by the resolution of the congress,...
...I have directed that the following initial steps be taken immediately.
To halt this offensive buildup, a strict quarantine on all offensive military equipment under shipment to Cuba is being initiated.
All ships of any kind bound for Cuba from whatever nation or port will, if found to contain cargoes of offensive weapons, be turned back.
It shall be the policy of this nation to regard any nuclear missile launched from Cuba against any nation in the Western hemisphere...
...as an attack by the Soviet Union on the United States, requiring a full retaliatory response upon the Soviet Union.
I call upon Chairman Khrushchev to halt and eliminate this clandestine, reckless, and provocative threat to world peace...
...and the stable relations between our two nations.
I call upon him further to abandon this course of world domination, and to join in a historic effort...
...to end the perilous arms race and to transform the history of man.
Our goal is not the victory of might, but the vindication of right;...
...not peace at the expense of freedom, but both peace and freedom...
...here in this hemisphere, and we hope, around the world.
God willing, that goal will be achieved.